get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
every week we pick a few of our writers
for them to read out their articles to
you
this week christopher snowden from the
institute of economic affairs
writes about just why white
working-class boys are falling behind in
their studies
we're also bringing you our leading
article of the week which talks about
the government's inconsistent messaging
on easing the lockdown
and at the very end you'll hear toby
young our status anxiety columnist
who writes about why his name is in
jeffrey epstein's little black book
first up here's christopher snowden you
can argue about the merits of pulling
down statues
but it's hard to make the case that mass
protests are of no useful purpose
at the very least they can provoke
debate and draw attention to
uncomfortable topics that might
otherwise be ignored
the recent protests have forced everyone
to have difficult discussions about
race class poverty entertainment any
serious examination of the statistics
shows that we're still far from equal
but what the figures also show is that
it's wrong-headed and
damaging to lump very different groups
together
in these discussions politicians often
lazily assume
that all black asian and minority ethnic
or being
people are the same and that all white
groups are equally privileged
but a proper look at the data shows not
just that there are striking differences
within bain groups
but that the very worst performing group
of all are white working class boys
the forgotten demographic it might seem
divisive to compare different groups but
attainment in education and in life is
relative and if we're to help the worst
off
we have to know who they are it is vital
to be able to compare groups to know
who's falling behind
bangladeshi brits earn 20 less than
whites on average for instance
but those with indian heritage are
likely to earn 12
more black britons on average and 9
less but chinese earn 30 more
these differences suggest that employers
are not systematically discriminating
against people on the basis of their
skin color and that we have to look
elsewhere
to see the roots of inequality
ucas the university admission service
can provide unique insight
into these issues it is the only outfit
in the world to gather detailed
information on all university applicants
including their age gender neighborhood
and school type
this is collected along with data on who
applied for which
courses and who was accepted and it is
renewed in huge detail every year
much of the data shows predictable
results there is a gap between
rich and poor as you might expect in a
uk state system where the best schools
tend to be located
in the most expensive areas but there
are surprising discoveries too
nearly half the children eligible for
free school meals in inner london
go on to higher education but in the
country outside london as a whole
it is just 26 black african british
children
outperform white children whereas black
caribbean children tend to do worse
poor chinese girls that is to say those
who qualify
for free school meals do better than
rich white children
but the ethnic group least likely to get
into university are whites
with the sole exception of gypsy roma
every ethnic group
attends university at a higher rate than
the white british
and of the white british who do attend
most the middle class
and 57 are female the least likely group
to go on to higher education are poor
white boys at just
13 this is a trend that can also be seen
in the gcse data
only 17 of white british pupils eligible
for preschool meals
achieve a strong pass in english and
maths students categorized as
bangladeshi black african and indian
are more than twice as likely to do so
in 2007 the state sector saw 23 percent
of black students go on to higher
education
this was also true for 22 percent of
whites
so about the same but at the last count
in 2018
the gap had widened to 11 points 41 for
black students
30 for whites the children of the white
working class are falling away from
their peers
in danger of becoming lost now going to
university is not the golden ticket it
once was but
it requires stupefying naivety to
believe that seven out of eight
poor white boys take a sober look at the
economics of higher education
and choose to set up their own
businesses instead the trail of hard
evidence runs cold once they leave
school
but the prospects for those who can
barely read and write are dreadful
and we can get some idea of the
consequences by looking at the left
behind areas
where unemployment crime and deaths of
despair is significantly higher than the
national average
angus deaton a nobel laureate based at
princeton university came up with the
phrase deaths of despair when he looked
at the demographics of those suffering
from alcoholism depression and drug
abuse
suicides among whites he found were
soaring and those who took their own
lives tended to be poor and low educated
his recently published book on the
subject deaths of despair and the future
of capitalism
co-written with ann case tells a
devastating story of what he calls the
decline of white working class lives
over the last half century yet while
white working-class males are the
largest disadvantaged minority
their cause is the least fashionable in
the intersectional pyramid of victimhood
white males are at the bottom tarnished
by ideas of
toxic masculinity and white privilege
despite the fact that in britain
class has always been the most
significant indicator of true privilege
it's worrying then that anyone who
attempts positive action on behalf of
poor white boys
faces a hostile reaction last year
dulich and winchester colleges turned
down a bequest of more than one million
pounds
because the donor sir brian thwaites
wanted the money ring fence for
scholarships for white working-class
boys
peter lampell founder of the sutton
trust a charity whose stated mission is
to improve social mobility
described kuwait's offer as obnoxious
when ben bradley the conservative mp
from mansfield tried to ask an
equality's question about white
working-class boys in parliament earlier
this year he was turned down by the
table office because they do not have
any protected characteristics
the concept of protected characteristics
was wheeled into uk law
by harriet harmon's equality act ten
years ago
and the tories then in opposition took
the rare step of voting for it
the nine protected characteristics
include race sex
and sexual orientation but the table
office is not alone in interpreting
these as
non-white female and gay
under the equality act positive
discrimination remains technically
unlawful
but the barely indistinguishable concept
of positive action
is explicitly legal firms cannot have
quotas but they can set targets
employers cannot refuse to look at job
applications from people who lack
protected characteristics
but by stating that applications are
particularly welcome
from bam female or lgbtq
plus candidates they can send a message
that certain people need not apply
in 2016 the bbc pledged that half its
workforce and leadership would be female
by 2020
despite less than 40 percent of
britain's full-time workers being women
it also set an eight percent target for
lgbt employees
although only around two percent of the
population identify as such
this target has been comfortably
exceeded as has
the target of having 15 of employees
from a
background in the wake of the black
lives matter protest last month
the corporation raised this target to 20
the bbc admits that people from low and
intermediate
income households are hugely
underrepresented in its workforce
but what does it do about it earlier
this month oxford university proudly
reported that it was making steady
progress
in its efforts to make its campuses
representative of wider society
of its most recent intake of british
students only 14 percent
came from the poorest 40 of households
this fits a pattern at a push we can
hear acknowledgement of the poor white
male
problem but that's as far as it ever
goes
the underperformance of white boys and
men is not considered to be a problem
worth solving
when figures come out showing the
stunning attainment gaps between boys
and girls
the interest lasts for about a day it
always got a few headlines says mary
kerner cook
the former head of ucas where it never
got any traction at all was in
policymaking in government
i began to think the subject of white
boys is just too difficult for them
given the politicization
of feminism and women's equality when i
asked a teacher why
white working-class boys have fallen so
far behind he gave me a short answer
girls are better behaved and immigrant
parents are stricter
this is a generalization but nonetheless
interesting
if it is the case that parenting is a
problem then it's not clear how much the
government can do
perhaps the reluctance to discuss the
subject stems from
fear that such a discussion would lead
to difficult territory
about family structure quality of
parenting and
in short culture perhaps politicians
think it better to let the problem
fester and the children suffer
than to risk discussing it last month
the government announced that its
commission
on racial inequality would include an
examination into the
underperformance of white working-class
boys at school
will it look deep into the causes it
might look at recent studies that
suggest poor reading levels in schools
is a huge part of the problem
and it might ask whether positive action
in the name of diversity
has left white working-class boys behind
that was
christopher snowden and now our leading
article
the mask slips when michael gove
delivered the ditchley annual lecture
last month
he spoke about why citizens feel that
the political system has failed them
he said the compact leaders offered
trust that we are the best
trust that we have your best interests
at heart and trust that we will deliver
was broken it was a powerful message
voters have a right to expect honesty
and competence from their leaders
not just decisiveness so mr gove will
have thought carefully before saying on
television last weekend
that face masks should not be mandatory
and people should instead be left to use
their own judgment
no one it seems told him that the prime
minister was hours away from asking the
police to enforce the wearing of masks
in shops
with a hundred pound fine for failure to
comply
paul suggests sixty percent of the
public support this move
but the proportion of government
scientific advisors who agree is harder
to ascertain
here's chris whitty the chief medical
officer in march
our advice is clear that wearing a mask
if you don't have
an infection really reduces the risk or
almost none not at all so we do not
advise that
his deputy professor jonathan van tam
was also emphatic
there is no evidence he said that the
wearing of face masks by healthy members
of the public slows the spread of the
virus
at one stage companies who advertised
masks as a tool against the virus were
prosecuted by the advertising standards
authority for making misleading claims
dr jenny harris another of mr wittey's
deputies
argued that masks can make things worse
because they can be stored
in dirty places and become containers
for infection
she said in march and in fact you can
actually trap the virus in the mask and
then start breathing in
and yes dr harris did acknowledge there
was disagreement between experts about
the efficacy of masks
but what does that tell us the fact that
there is a lot of debate
means that the evidence that either
isn't clear or is is weak
at the height of the pandemic number 10
was keen to say that it was taking the
advice of experts and would not be
swayed by
manias panic social media or opinion
polls
the prime minister rightly pointed out
that if governments feel they need to be
seen to act they can cause harm his
broader point was to give the public
confidence that in times of crisis the
government would not act as a
weathervane
and that when the virus subsided things
could go back to normal
yet now it seems as if focus groups are
as influential to this government's
decision-making as scientific advisors
there is little rationale for the
quarantines for overseas visitors
but this polls well there have been
u-turns over the test and trace system
the now-abandoned app and the return of
schools
it is this accumulation of leadership
failures which erodes confidence that
the government can deliver
the decision to embark on a large
shake-up of the civil service midway
through a pandemic has only added to a
sense of drift
this as mr gove says goes back to trust
there has been talk for example that
masks will now be made compulsory even
in offices government sources say this
is improbable
but as mr gove can attest things change
fast
and the confusion goes beyond face masks
last week the prime minister said that
the stay at home if you can advice
should be changed to
go to work if you can but was he talking
ex-officio
or off-the-cuff it was hard to tell as
the official advice remained unchanged
robert buckland the justice secretary
later sought to clear up the confusion
work from home if you can if you are
able to do things remotely
then carry on but also work with your
employer
or the firm or the particular entity
you're with
and you increasingly we will see more
and more people
coming back to work in a staggered way
but in a safe way as well
i think the message is yes come back to
work talk to your employer make your own
judgment or a workplace judgment how is
any employer supposed to make plans on
this basis
masks it seems are not being made
mandatory for public health reasons
but to inspire confidence to get people
out and about
but there is a risk that this will
backfire that masks will reinforce the
idea that the virus is still very much
at large
covid19 has now receded in the vast
majority of the country
but rather than publicize this ministers
introduce edicts and restrictions that
were deemed excessive at the height of
the pandemic
this risks sending another message that
the threat is perhaps larger than is
being let on
surely it would be better as mr gove
originally suggested
to have an honest conversation over the
data the risks
and the extent to which masks are likely
to help reluctance to do so
would suggest a lack of respect for the
electorate or people's
ability to draw their own conclusions
the prime minister recently said that
the public could forgive ministers
making mistakes
on the way into the pandemic but would
not forgive blunders made on the way out
of it
he may be about to test the second part
of this theory
that was our leading article and now
toby young
on why his name appears in jeffrey
epstein's little black book
every time jeffrey epstein is in the
news i start getting calls from
strangers
wanting to scream abuse at me this
happened a lot when the billionaire
financier
was found dead in his jail cell last
year after being arrested on
sex trafficking charges and it started
again
following the arrest of his
ex-girlfriend elaine maxwell
a couple of weeks ago the reason is that
my contact details
were in epstein's little black book
and whenever his name pops up some
kindly soul takes it upon themselves
to post a picture of the relevant page
which shows my mobile phone number
on twitter i may have to change my
number so frequent of the calls become
on one level it's quite flattering in a
piece about the book last year
the new york times described it as a
symbol of the exclusive world
of the very famous and very rich
and it does read like the modern day
equivalent of
the 400 the creme de la creme of
international society
compiled by the social arbiter ward
mcallister
and printed in the new york times in
1892
among the names of the little black book
are donald trump
bill clinton prince andrew mick jagger
ted kennedy
alan dershowitz courtney love peter
mandelson
and ray fines my details appear opposite
those of
yugoslavia prince michaelov i can
honestly say
hand on heart i've no idea how i ended
up
in epstein's address book i never met
him and never set foot in any of his
houses
let alone on his private island not that
anyone believes me when i say this
ever since the contents of the book were
published on a gossip website in 2015
the people in it have been frantically
protesting their innocence
charles finch the film producer told the
new york times he had
no idea why his name was there as did
vanessa von bismarck
the founder of a pr company joan juliet
buck
the former editor of french vogue said
as far as i know
i have never met epstein i never went to
any of those famous parties
at the biggest house in new york city
to the conspiracy theorists piecing
together the web-like connections
between the dramatis personae
these denials might as well be
admissions of guilt
my best guess is that in reality the
address book belonged to gillane
whom i do know slightly when i lived in
new york between 1995 and 2000
i bumped into her occasionally at
parties and the london address listed as
mine
dates back to that period i sometimes
worry
about a mob of enraged pedo hunters
turning up outside my old shepherd's
bush bedsit
and demanding justice rather unhelpfully
the daily mail recently ran a picture
spread showing gillane
out and about in society and included
a photo of me saying something funny to
her in a nightclub
making her howl with laughter ever since
that picture has been posted dozens of
times on twitter
alongside the relevant page in the
little black book
as if it were proof that i was a member
of epstein's inner circle
its guilt by association although as i
point out to the screamers on the other
end of the phone
gillane hasn't actually been found
guilty of anything
needless to say the concept of innocent
until proven guilty
doesn't cut much ice with them
the little black book first surfaced in
2012
when alfredo rodriguez epstein's former
housekeeper
was arrested by the fbi while trying to
sell it for
fifty thousand dollars somehow it fell
into the hands of an investigative
journalist called nick bryant
as did the passenger logs of epstein's
private jet
nicknamed the lolita express and he
published them both three years ago
on gorka and now defunct gossip website
happily
my name isn't on the manifest of the
lolita express
although the company there is even more
exalted than in the address book
in addition to bill clinton prince
andrew and alan dershowitz
the names include naomi campbell chris
tucker and kevin spacey
had gillane offered me a lift to london
on it back in the mid-1990s
before epstein was suspected of any
crimes i would have accepted
thank god for small nurses i sometimes
wonder
why none of the other people in the
little black book have had their
personal details shared on twitter
there's at least one other ex-labor mp
in there in addition to blair and mandy
i dare say it's because i'm a tory in
the eyes of the
basement dwelling left we're all
suspected pedos
that was toby young thanks for listening
to this episode of spectator out loud
as ever do send over your thoughts and
suggestions and who else you might like
to hear
on the podcast to podcast spectator dot
co dot uk
do join us again next week
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher